what is it that's so alluring about that
cynical mindset
I I don't I don't know what I hate more
than cynicism you know maybe like you
know literal totalitarianism but in
terms of personality I don't know what I
hate more and what I'm more against
because
it's such an absurd
premise that's so easily disprovable uh
cynicism as I understand it not in the
you know uh you know Greek philosophical
sense but this idea that like
everything sucks
or you know don't get your hopes up it's
not going to work out
as long as you have one counter example
the thesis is disproven
and you're telling me that like and like
if people are like um uh
uh you know I agree that most comedians
suck
I agree that most movies suck I agree
that most books suck I agree that most
podcasts suck especially mine
none of them now one there's no book
that you read that you're a better
person having read it there's no movie
you've seen where you're like holy crap
I feel like I'm watching something from
Heaven there's no song that you've ever
heard that even when you hear it for the
20th time it shakes your soul none
and if you're that kind of person
that's on you that means you are somehow
guarded or damaged or something within
uh and I think there is an enormous
amount of pressure
uh and from what you and I have talked
about it's I guess more prevalent in
British culture than America but there
is a lot of pressure of you know kind of
just head down go to the factory do the
work don't hope for anything better and
it's just like
you don't have to become
a king or a president or a CEO to
improve right not everyone has to be a
fitness model to be in better shape
right if you're someone who's 400 pounds
you can get down to 250 you're still a
big dude but think how much Healthy You
Are
your clothes Mobility walking up the
stairs quality of life in every way is
that's such an unreasonable goal but for
a cynic it's like what's the point
you're still fat well yeah you are but
come on these are extremely different
qualities of life so I think it is a
very non-rational
um emotional
perspective that tries to present itself
as it's as if it's realistic and
cool-headed it's like oh you're naive
you're you're a Pollyanna and like you
pointed out the point this book is
I'm not being hopeful in the sense of
nothing bad happens I'm not being
hopeful in the sense of the bad guys
aren't really that bad the extent of the
depravity in you know I I was on my
buddy uh Dave Smith he's a very failed
comedian in his podcast and he goes if
you read 90 of this book you think it's
the black pill correct because you're
reading it and you're like that's what I
mean I'm like okay chapter 10 it was
still not here and you're you're like I
just one you know example off the top of
my head I hope I get through with that
my voice breaking because I still
read it and just it just haunts me to my
core you know early in the 1920s there
are these children who were like
homeless in Moscow and they were like
thieves pickpockets you know your kid
living on the streets you gotta make do
so the Checker come the secret police
round them up and they take them to the
cellar of the prison and they start
beating them and torturing them and
making them who who are you working with
who are your uh colleagues whatever the
term they used right in your gang they
don't they're kids they don't so they
take them in the car and they drive
around they go point out who you're and
at that point you're like yeah him him
you know anyone and then they took them
back and they kept beating them and you
hear the other prisoners like the adults
hearing these kids these kids screaming
and these adult criminals are like they
were losing their minds just hearing the
screens the children as the children
realized they're being returned to the
seller so when you hear about the so
there's no whitewashing in this book of
how bad it gets you know know but people
have this idea that like there's no
point in fighting because you know it's
inevitable that the bad guys are going
to win but they haven't you know like
I'm here if Hitler had his way I'd be
dead if Hitler had his way you'd be dead
right like you know Britain was standing
alone against Hitler for quite a while
uh or you'd be a slave I don't know what
you'd be whatever point being you know
this insistence that villainy always why
is it you know this is the line I had
you know one thing about this book why
is it that the bad guys always get what
they want well I can't get what I want
once and when you put in those terms
it's like yeah you're right and even if
I can't what I'm just going to be like
ah too bad so I I don't think it's a
coherent
um worldview I think it's a very
emotional response coached in the mask
of rationality and realism and I don't
think it's realistic at all
it's able to give people it's a much
more
um sort of pedestalized position to be
in right if you say that everything's
going to be bad it's it feels like a
well researched the critic always feels
like the guy that's well researched yeah
right right as opposed to the person
that's hopeful because the person that's
hopeful that things don't happen have
and maybe this is actually reflected in
terms of our neurochemistry Andrew human
taught me about this thing where if you
tell someone that a movie is going to be
really really good that dopamine release
even if it's as good as they expect it
to be is less and if the movie is less
good than they expected it to be then
they lose even more sure so what you're
doing is by being the cynic you're
saving yourself from ever being the
person that over promises so maybe
reality does deliver the world better
than you'd hoped well brilliant that's a
bonus for you and oh well you know I'm
just trying to keep everybody's feet on
the ground that seems like a noble cause
right what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]